hallo leute ich sie teure mal wanne und
bevor es mit dem video loslegen möchte
ich euch etwas zeigen
[Gelächter]
mein kopf unsere star leute und das wie
schmeckt was sie heute sät wird aus dem
kochbuch stammen ich habe es noch nie
vorher gesehen und jetzt ist der
glorreichen moment gekommen
wir schauen es uns okay ich schaff mir
noch nicht einmal raus
[Musik]
also des postens ticker naja wenn man es
neutral halten will und nicht wegen mir
kauft dann kann man es auch
also das ist das buch okay
die tipps wie leicht ist die seiten sind
auch sehr dick und sehr schön und mein
gold mega wenn ihr zu einer
signierstunde kommt dann werde ich euch
hier da sowas draufschreiben hammer du
bist eingestellt das ist es bietet man
das inhaltsverzeichnis mit
ich kann ja jetzt nicht so viel zeigen
schließt man den ersten satz vor hallo
leute hier ist wieder einmal wanne an
gesagt dass ich drei tage
wie fange ich begrüßen dann steht hier
halt noch sein tags müsst ihr heiße
kaufen uns gelesen es war einfach so
schön gedrückt
es funktioniert ich habe die ganze zeit
gesagt ich möchte so farbige ränder
haben dass wenn man so seitlich cook
dass man sehen kann man so sehen kann
es wurden die kategorien gehen weißt du
jetzt in die seiten so gestreift bund
hat es nicht gereicht aber es war okay
da hab ich ein rezept wie kelly die
kategorien kategorien seiten kann ich ja
schon zeigen kino film animation
zeichentrick und anime serie ist auch
eine kategorie und haben noch party
snacks und drinks und das die einzige
kategorie in der ich nichts nach koche
sondern also schon aber nichts aus
filmen oder serien sondern eher so zum
beispiel so karamell und drinks und um
die meistgestellten fragen jetzt mal zu
beantworten
das buch ist nicht explizit vegan oder
vegetarisch also da gibt es halt alles
für veganer
naja wenn man so ersatzprodukte benutzt
dann kann man zum beispiel alles ja
wigan nachmachen und die meisten rezepte
die man hier findet habe ich noch nicht
weil wie schmeckt's gemacht ein paar
gibt es schon sich bei wie schmeckt's
gemacht haben aber die meisten rezepte
sind exklusiv und gibt es nur hier drin
und alle fotos in rezepte wie hier
findet habe ich alle selbst fotografiert
mit einer anderen person zusammen
benjamin blümchen ich habe alles gekocht
alles erstellt wenn es was zu meckern
gibt dann bitte direkt an mich das ist
nämlich aus meinem kopf für euch ein
geschenk jetzt geht es los mit dem video
und ihr findet natürlich den link zum
kochbuch unten in der beschreibung das
buch erscheint am 29 märz also jetzt
könnt ihr es noch vorbestellen und ab 29
märz gibt's das dann auch im handel und
wo ihr euch das sonst holen wollt aber
wenn ihr den link unten benutzt dann
hätte mir sogar ein bisschen weiter nach
unterstützung ist cool
viel spaß mit dem video heute machen wie
die bacon beer cup cakes aus tobruk
[Applaus]
aber vanessa woher wissen wir dann wie
das prozess geht ganz einfach wir nehmen
das rezept aus dem neuen kochbuch wie
schmeckt das letzte mal habe ich das als
typen gefragt
das rezept müssen wir unter serien so
viele rezepte kein wunder dass
zugenommen hat und hier ist es auch
schon und für den tage brauchen wir am
weiche butter 2 eier 150 gramm circa 100
milliliter einziges bier oder malzbier
wir wollen ja nicht so alkoholisch
machen 50 milliliter milch
200 gramm mehl eine krise zwar
natürliche saal 2 esslöffel kakaopulver
oder wie ich es nennen würde altes koks
und ein gehäufte teelöffel backpulver
und so werden sie zubereitet für den
teig butter und zucker in einer schüssel
nix also ich bin unseren mixa für ganz
andere sachen bier und milch zu geben
und noch einmal hören wie das sprint
entschieden
in einer zweiten schüssel mehl salz
kakaopulver und backpulver mischen und
dann betroffene mischung nach und nach
mit der flüssigen masse verrührt bis ein
glatter teig entsteht
teamworx streamwork
die macht in förmchen mit dem papier
förmchen auslegen und darauf verteilt
[Musik]
ich habe mir da nicht gerade hoch geehrt
wird
das unbewusste tut richtig im herzen weh
aber so ist das auch so gnadenlos ich
halt eine woche will ich finde es für 20
bis 25 minuten bei 180 grad umluft im
vorgeheizten backofen backen nach die
nach handys komplett abkühlen lassen
ich wusste gar nicht dass lesen kannst
und während wir warten druck jetzt
machen wir weiter mit dem frosting und
für string brauchen wir drei esslöffel
ahornsirup 200 gramm reto furter 200
gramm fisch 130 gramm puderzucker oder
wie ich sage ganz frisches koks und ein
halber teelöffel vanille extrakt und
jetzt legen wir das magma vier auf eins
und jetzt machen wir drei scheiben
die müssen wir dann besser und jetzt
müssen wir den ahornsirup auf den bänken
verstreichen
und wenn die machen es draußen sind kann
das in und während wir warten und jetzt
holen wir die muffins aus dem ofen und
stecken den banken in den ofen bereit
für das frosting müssen wir jetzt butter
und freeski miteinander verrühren
der kopf
jetzt drehen wir den puderzucker durch
ein sieb nach und nach zu der mutter und
dem frisch in den knast bringen banken
das kapital anlocken und jetzt knuspern
wir so kleine stücke anständiges mund
vorbei und das sagte sich auch die szene
wo sie sich beide unterhalten und ja
zusammen wie cupcakes fertigstellen und
jetzt habt ihr dieses becken konfetti
guter tipp zwischendurch wie creme im
kühlschrank damit sie schön fest für den
richtigen taze komplizieren wandel
extrakt um braucht ein halber pele und
jetzt noch einmal verdienen
jetzt muss die masse in den spritzbeutel
wenn man den sprichwörtern über ein
glasstück da
einfach genau und dann das machen wir
mit euch männern
ich weiß jetzt wie man das macht wir
toppen den cupcake jetzt mit dem beten
[Musik]
richtig gut abgesprochen
da kann sie unsere bacon beer cup cakes
bin so stolz auf mich eine befüllung was
die stelle ist und wie ihr dieses rezept
nach machen könnt findet ihr natürlich
auch in meinem kochbuch den link zu
meinem kochbuch findet in der
beschreibung es wäre ganz toll kann sich
jeder freuen wenn ihr mich unterstützt
und euch dieses buch bolt es ist wie
kelly sagt auch einbruch in das man
einfach durchblättern kann sowie center
technik auch anzugucken
und nun stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmecken die
banken birgt
[Musik]
sie finden dass so eine mischung aus
show gemacht käsekuchen und dann
natürlich herzhaften selbst mit
ahornsirup drauf lag heute macht sie
doch mal nach und verlinkt scott kelly
vorbei abonnieren sie schreibt mir meine
gute geschenkideen für girlies zwei
millionen geschenkt wir arbeiten
[Musik]